storms are also creating more chaos for
air travelers in the last two days more
than fifteen thousand flights were
delayed across the u.s and more than
twenty three hundred others were
canceled transportation secretary pete
buddha judge is pushing airlines to help
travelers affected by these types of
disruptions chris van cleeve spoke to
the secretary who admits the flight
cancellation system is not where it
needs to be
another punishing stretch for summer
travelers facing a flurry of flight
disruptions
our flight was canceled
now we're back again today
it was canceled this morning and now
we're back again severe weather pounded
dallas more than half of the flights at
one of the nation's busiest airports
were delayed or canceled monday and
nationally nearly a quarter of all
flights offered by u.s carriers have
experienced delays since the beginning
of august by an average of 52 minutes i
actually have a flight today that was
cancelled rebooked and has had like
three changes to it seems like if i did
my job the way the airlines do i
wouldn't have one this is the customer
service line for united tonight
at denver's airport dozens of flights
were canceled over the last two days
prompting united airlines to offer
stranded passengers cots how are the
airlines doing so the good news is we've
seen some improvement the bottom line is
it's still not an acceptable level of
delays and cancellations weather issues
happen but they cascade through the
system because the system is not yet
able to cope a system transportation
secretary pete butterjudge says could
take months to fix in part because
airlines and air traffic control are
dealing with major staffing shortages
there are several things that could be
done first of all making sure that
hiring is stepped up two they need to be
ready with customer service and luis
coons and her daughter molly were
delayed in denver for several hours
before their flight to sacramento was
ultimately canceled [ __ ] says it set
them back nearly a full day and cost
them more than a thousand dollars to get
out on another airline i think it's this
kind of like hunger games feeling that
you have when it happens because you're
kind of everybody's on their own and you
can't really reach anybody to help
and it's still pretty early in the
travel day and already more than 400
flights in the u.s have been canceled
now the department of transportation is
planning to roll out a new website in
the coming days that will lay out what
options are available to passengers on
all of the us airlines when there are
flight disruptions the department is
also working on new regulations
regarding refunds when there are lengthy
flight delays david
chris van cleave in arlington this
morning thank you chris